[Music]
the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulder this is my chance to prove
myself
that's not a hug and just grab the door
for you oh all right kid good luck out
there now whatever you do don't push
this but because that will set off the
bomb immediately and we'll all be dead
everybody now repeat back what I just
said oh no that's the button it will
kill everyone
[Music]
Showtime a-holes
does anybody have any paper out there I
want to put some tape over the death but
nobody has any tape not a single person
has paint you have an atomic bomb in
your bag if anybody's gonna have that's
a really bad sign
if I touch someone I can feel their
feelings your feel yeah yeah I guess
yeah I feel a general unselfish love for
your sweater no sexual no no I don't
know
see you stole everyone your deepest
darkest secret dude come on I think
you're overreacting a little
you must be so embarrassed
hey youtubers we are Groot there's gonna
be a whole bunch of Superbowl trailers
next week so this is gonna be a
breakdown of what's going on if you
don't care about the Superbowl don't
worry
most of this stuff posts online I'll be
doing videos for everything so just be
sure to subscribe to get everything make
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
I'll be doing all kinds of Super Bowl
giveaways it'll be great
so the really big stuff first DC doesn't
have any official Super Bowl trailers
that they've announced that means Wonder
Woman Justice League they didn't drop
any Super Bowl trailers last year but
their promotional partners like Turkish
Airlines aired those weird trailers
destination Gotham City a city that's
risen above its past to become a
thriving urban center thanks to a
significant grant from my company Wayne
Enterprises Gotham is being restored to
its former so there was stuff dropping
for Batman vs Superman that might also
happen with Justice League and Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman is coming out way
sooner than Justice League though so if
there is any kind of DC stuff happening
they'll probably be teasing Wonder Woman
gal gadot was recently teasing some
behind the scenes Justice League stuff
they're doing voiceover for that they've
shot the movie they're editing it right
now Wonder Woman is also rapping
scouring the film they're doing the
music for it but the film itself is done
they're getting ready for a really big
campaign so just expect them to tease
little things throughout the week on
social media but I'm not expecting any
really big trailers during the Super
Bowl she and Jason Statham are also
doing a separate Super Bowl ad that has
nothing to do with the DC movies it's
for like a website company they play a
couple badasses in a restaurant that
just beat the [ __ ] out of a lot of
people so that's something that's
completely different
a lot of you are also asking about Star
Wars they're not officially buying any
airtime but they've been teasing stuff
for behind the scenes like the opening
title crawl
they'll probably continue to do that
through the week with little teasers
just behind the scenes stuff it's still
very early it's not coming out till
December so there's not gonna be a whole
lot of really big video stuff happening
but the really good news is that Marvel
definitely has some really cool stuff
they've confirmed there's gonna be a
guardians of the galaxy 2 trailer so
that'll mean a bunch of new footage they
usually only do a small version of that
on TV and then a longer version online
so there'll be a whole bunch of new
stuff to dig through I'm not expecting
them to reveal ego the Living Planet but
they might explain a little bit more
about the story because they've already
released that first trailer usually
that's just like a mishmash of like the
big moments the funny things like oh
look baby Groot skewed he doesn't know
what's going on it's gonna be crazy the
next trailer after that is usually a
story based trailer that explains what
actually happens what the villains are
doing why the guardians are fighting
this big creature here why the Ravagers
turn against them just explaining what
the hell's going on
ego the Living Planet is probably gonna
be saved for the very last trailer they
did the same thing with Ultron when they
were marketing age of Ultron they saved
him for the last trailer and they did
the same thing with Spider Man when they
were marketing Civil War biggest stuff
always gets saved for last and guardians
isn't coming out to the beginning of May
so speaking of Spider Man everybody
freaking out there supposed to be some
new Spider Man dropping Sony hasn't
officially announced what they're doing
but there's going to be some sort of
Spider Man stuff happening this week
they bought a Super Bowl trailer for
their last big spider-man movie with
Andrew Garfield but that movie was
coming out earlier in the year but
that's the only really really big movie
that they have coming out that is going
to make Bank they have a couple other
big movies there's a lot of talk about
Sony selling its film business Marvel
buying them meaning that they would get
all those spider-man characters back but
that's a whole other thing so I'll do a
separate video about that explaining
what's going on soon if they do drop a
legit trailer it'll be the same deal as
guardians just more story like this is
what the vulture is doing this is what
the villains are trying to do this is
how spider-man start
fighting them this is the reason he runs
into them so it'll just explain what the
hell's going on next big studio is Fox
for their x-men stuff which is Logan but
they also have the new alien covenant
movie that's coming out later in the
year my bet is that they'll drop some
new Logan because that movie is coming
out really soon but the last trailer
they dropped they called the final
trailer so anything new that they drop
in terms of footage would probably be
just teasers flashes of x-23 Weapon X
step just explaining a little bit more
about the story a little bit more of
Hugh Jackman most people are expecting
Hugh Jackman to get people into the
theaters but most of the comic book
people want to know what's going on with
x-23 the last big other movies is all
paramount stuff that's transformers the
last night in Fast & Furious the funny
thing with both of these movies is that
they almost have the exact same story
the good guys going bad in the bad guys
going good Optimus Prime
poison with dark Energon going bad
Megatron becoming one of the heroes and
then in the Fast and the Furious movie
DOM is being forced to go bad by the
villain in Jason Statham the villain of
the last movie is now working with the
heroes what a coincidence that they're
both trading on the same themes whatever
ends up happening I'll totally do videos
for all the big comic-book stuff
sometimes they'll drop teasers during
the week leading up into like the big
Superbowl trailers so if there's
anything cool I will totally do a video
for it but feel free to leave your
requests in the comments below but all
that stuff will start posting on Sunday
normally I try to do Game of Thrones on
Sunday so I'll try to schedule around
that depending on what's happening
because it'll be like Super Bowl
trailers all day long it'll be crazy but
it'll be really really cool and if you
don't care about the Super Bowl don't
worry as long as you have alerts enabled
you'll just see all the trailers as I
post them what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for new Black
Panther they just started filming and
infinity war and you can click here for
new Star Wars Episode eight thank you so
much for watching everyone
the type I've I'll see you in the next
video